[Music]
from the director responsible for all
things Tim Allen comes the film that
asked children's who imagine what if
Santa was real and what if he was a
legally binding curse and flickered on
whoever stole the pants off Santa's dead
body the Santa Claus this movie is why a
whole generation can't spell his name
huh return to the Christmas of 90s past
aha we're just like a pop star making a
half-baked Christmas album actors at the
height of their powers would pump out a
half-baked Christmas movie that you
think is a Class A because you were a
kid when it came out and didn't know any
better meet Scott Calvin a careerist
jerk he's fighting his jerk ex-wife and
her jerk boyfriend over custody of their
jerk kid would you please be quiet but
when he fourth degree murder Santa Claus
he'll take his job give it his own jerk
flair do you want this doll or not go
back to sleep
get fat shamed by his jerk coworkers
they're starting to look like the
Pillsbury Doughboy then loses career
clean legal record and son in the
process
happy holidays I guess experience a film
all about the magic of Christmas that
sucks all the magic out of Christmas
where Santa isn't a man but a job title
se to die so often the rules of
succession are printed on his business
card and Santa's physique isn't a choice
but a virus that twists the hosts body
into a santa chic mask from which there
is no escape
hm I wonder what would happen if a woman
killed Santa were a child or a dog I'm
Santa Paws now they made a movie out of
that - woof
prepare to believe again specifically
the belief that therapy is for losers
from doctors and psychiatrists as this
broken family drama makes it clear Santa
and psychiatry don't mix he's not Santa
where not only is all mental health
advice stupid but the whole reason the
hero believes in Santa is to get revenge
on his ex-wife for dating a shrink well
Neal's head comes to a point go ahead
dr. Miller I guess we know who's the
teacher's pet Scott they charges you for
oh ho holy moly someone's got some
issues to work on journey to the North
Pole for a strange new take on Santa's
workshop with its own paramilitary squad
that operates outside of human law we're
your worst nightmare eternal child
brides trained to service Santa's every
need look pretty good for your age and
Bernard a cruel taskmaster who keeps the
workers toiling away through stations
excuse me are we on a coffee break and
blackmail senator leaving his old life
behind
or else Christmas is dead for everyone
you wouldn't want to be responsible for
killing the spirit of Christmas now
would you there is no way this place as
a union so revisit this 90s throwback
that makes everyone's fantasies come
true from kids fantasies that Santa is
real parents fantasies that their
children will respect them the studio's
fantasies that this movie deserved a
trilogy and Tim Allen's fantasy that he
wouldn't immediately crack in a police
interrogation named shoe show unlike you
know what actually happened look it up
stirring to festivity and Beyond Ryan
Stiles the kids that make your iPhone's
they can't all be JT T and the pimp from
true romance the set occurs
you'll make a great psychiatrist one day
kid no I think I'm gonna go into the
family business so you're gonna kill
your dad hey screen junkies we're
turning our January honest trailers over
to the fans click the link to vote for
the 2017 movie you want us to do
Avengers Assemble
I am the cheese I'm the best character
on the show I am better than both the
salami and the Bologna combined and get
this man a shield